everything we've been dealing with so
far and our journey through chemistry
has revolved around stability of
electrons and where electrons would
rather be in stable shells and like all
things in life we if you explore the
atom a little further you'll realize
that electrons are not the only stuff
that's going on in an atom that the
nucleus itself has has some interactions
or has some instability that needs to be
relieved in some way and that's what
we'll talk a little bit about in this
video so and and and actually the
mechanics of it or well out of the scope
of a first-year chemistry course but
it's good to at least know that it
occurs and one day when we we study the
strong nuclear force and quantum physics
and all the like that we could start
talking about exactly why why these
protons and neutrons and the their
constituent quarks are interacting the
way they do but with that said let's at
least think about the different types of
ways that a nucleus can can essentially
decay so let's say I have a bunch of
protons I'll just draw a couple here
some protons there and I'll draw some
neutrons and I'll draw them in a in a
neutral ish color maybe let me see like
a grayish would be good so let me just
draw some neutrons here
how many pros I have 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
I'll do 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 neutrons and
so let's say this is the nucleus of our
atom and remember and this was you know
in the very first video I made about the
atom the nucleus if you actually were to
draw the actual atom and it's actually
very hard to draw an atom because it has
no well-defined boundaries the electron
really could be you know at any given
moment it could be anywhere but if you
were to just say okay where's ninety
percent of the time the electron is
going to be and you say that's the
radius or that's the diameter of our
atom we learned in that very first video
that the nucleus is almost an
infinitesimal portion of the volume of
this of this sphere where the electron
will be 90% of the time and the neat
takeaway there was that well most of
whatever we look at in life is just
open free space all of this is just open
space but I just want to repeat that
because that little infinitesimal spot
that we talked about before where even
though it's a very small part of the
fraction of the volume of an atom it's
actually almost all of its mass that's
what I'm zooming out to this point here
these aren't atoms these aren't
electrons this is as we're zoomed into
the nucleus and so it turns out that
sometimes the nucleus is a little bit
unstable and it wants to get to a more
stable configuration we're not going to
go into the mechanics of exactly what
defines an unstable nucleus and all that
but in order to get into a more unstable
nucleus sometimes it emits what's called
an alpha particle or this is called
alpha decay alpha alpha decay and it
emits an alpha particle which sounds
very fancy and it's what it's just a
collection of neutrons and protons so an
alpha particle is two neutrons and two
protons so maybe maybe these guys they
just didn't feel like they fit in just
right so their collection right here and
they get emitted they leave they leave
the nucleus so let's just think what
happens to an atom when it's when
something like that happens so let's
just say I have some random element I'll
just call it element II let's say it has
P protons actually let me do it in the
color of my protons it has P protons and
then it has its atomic mass number is
the number of protons plus the number of
neutrons and in the neutrons in gray
right so when it says when it
experiences alpha decay when it
experiences alpha decay what happens to
the element well it's protons are going
to decrease by 2 so it's protons are
going to be P minus 2 and then it's it's
neutrons are also going to decrease by 2
so it's mass number is going to decrease
by 4 so up here you'll have P minus 2
plus our neutrons minus 2
so we're going to have minus 4 so your
mass is going to decrease by 4 and
you're actually going to turn into a new
element remember your elements were
defined by the number of protons so in
this alpha decay when you lose those as
you're losing 2 neutrons and two protons
but especially the protons are going to
make you into a different element so if
we call this element 1 I'm going to call
we're going to be at a different element
now element 2 and if you think about
what's generated so we're emitting
something that has two protons two
protons and it has two neutrons so
that's mass is going to be the mass of
the two protons and two neutrons so what
our readmitting we're meaning something
that has a mass of four so if you look
at what is two protons and two neutrons
actually don't I don't have the periodic
table on my I'd forgot to cut and paste
it before this video but it doesn't take
you long on the periodic table to find
an element that has two protons and
that's helium it actually has an atomic
mass of four so this is actually a
helium nucleus that gets emitted with
alpha decay this is actually a helium
nucleus a helium nucleus and because
it's a helium nucleus and it has no no
electrons to bounce off it's two protons
you would call this this would be a
helium ion so it essentially it has no
it has no electrons it has two protons
so it has a plus two charge plus two
charge so an alpha particle is really
just an a helium ion a plus two charge
helium ion that is spontaneously emitted
by a nucleus just to get to a more
stable State
now that's one type of decay let's
explore the other one so let me let me
draw another nucleus here I'll draw some
neutrons I'll just draw some protons
protons so it turns out sometimes that a
a neutron doesn't feel comfortable with
itself it wishes that it looks at what
the protons do on a daily basis and says
you know what for some reason when I
look into my heart I feel like I really
should be a proton if I were proton
the entire nucleus would be a little bit
more stable and so what it does is to
become a proton remember a neutron has
neutral charge so what it does is it
emits an electron and I know you're
saying Sal you know that's crazy I
didn't even know neutrons had electrons
in them and all of that and and I agree
with you it is crazy and and one day
we'll study all of all of what exists
inside of the nucleus but let's just say
that they it can emit an electron and
when it emits an electron so this emits
an electron so it emits an electron and
we signify that with it's roughly its
mass is zero we know an electron really
doesn't have a zero mass but we're
talking about atomic mass units if the
proton is one an electron is one 1,836
of that so we just round and we say it
has a mass of your mass really isn't
zero its mass and its charge is minus
one it's atomic you can kind of say it's
atomic number is minus one so it emits
an electron and by emitting an electron
instead of being neutral now it turns
into a proton it turns into a proton and
so this is called beta decay beta decay
beta decay and a beta particle is really
just that emitted electron so let's go
back to our little case of an element it
has some number of protons and then it
has some number of neutrons so you had
the protons and the neutrons and you get
your mass number when it experiences
beta decay what happens well are the
protons changed sure we have one more
proton than we had before because a
neutron changed into one so now our
protons are plus one has our mass number
changed well see this goes the neutrons
goes down by one but your protons go up
by one so your mass number will not
change so it's still going to be P plus
n so your mass stays the same unlike the
situation with alpha decay but your
element changes you're pro number of
protons changes so now you're once again
you're dealing with a new element in
beta decay now let's say we had the
other situation let's say we have a
situation where
one of these one of these protons looks
at the neutrons and says you know what I
I see how they live and it's very
appealing to me I think I would I would
fit in better and our community of
particles of we could call them nuclear
well we of particles within the nucleus
would be happier if I two were a neutron
we'd all be in a more stable condition
so what they do is that little
uncomfortable proton has some
probability of emitting and now this is
this is a new idea to you a positron not
a proton it emits a positron and what's
a positron it's something that has the
exact same mass as an electron so it's
one 1836 of the mass of a proton but we
just write a zero there because in
atomic mass units it's it's pretty close
to zero but it has a positive charge
it's a little confusing because they'll
still write a there whenever I see any I
see well I think an electron but no they
say E because it's kind of like the same
type of particle but instead of having a
negative charge it has a positive charge
this is a positron positron and now
we're getting we're starting to get kind
of exotic with our with the types of
particles and stuff we're dealing with
but this does happen and if you have a a
proton that emits this particle that
pretty much had all of its positive
charge going with it this proton turns
into a turns into a neutron and that is
called positron emission positron
emission is usually pretty easy to
figure out what it is because they call
it positron emission so if we start with
the same E it has certain number of
protons a certain number of neutrons
what's the new element going to be
what's going to lose a proton P minus 1
and that's going to be turned into a
neutron so P is going to go down by 1
and it's going to go up by 1 so that the
mass of the whole elect of the whole
atom isn't going to change so it's going
to be P plus n but we're still going to
have a different element right when we
had beta decay we increase the number of
protons so we went kind of to the right
in the periodic table or we increased
our well
you get the idea when we do positron
emission we decreased our our number of
protons and actually I should write that
here in both of these reactions so and
this is the positron emission and I'm
left over with one positron and in our
beta decay I'm left over with one
electron they're written the exact same
way you know this electron cuz it's a
minus one charge you notice as a
positron because it has a plus one
charge now there's one last type of
decayed that you should know about but
it doesn't change the number of protons
or neutrons and a nucleus but it just
released is a ton of energy or sometimes
you know a high-energy photon and that's
called gamma decay and gamma decay means
these guys just reconfigure themselves
maybe they get a little bit closer and
by doing that they release energy in the
form of a very high wavelength a
electromagnetic wave which is
essentially a gamma you could either
call it a gamma particle or a gamma
gamma ray and there's very high-energy
gamma rays or something you don't want
to be around they're very likely to
maybe kill you
so let's everything we did I have set a
little theoretical let's do some actual
problems and figure out what type of
decay we're dealing with so here I have
seven beryllium where seven is its
atomic mass and I haven't been converted
to seven lithium so what's going on here
my beryllium my my nuclear mass is
staying the same but I'm going from four
protons I'm going from four protons to
three protons so I'm reducing my number
of protons my overall mass hasn't
changed so it's not it's definitely not
alpha decay alpha decay was you know
you're releasing a whole helium from the
nucleus so what am i what am i releasing
I'm kind of releasing one positive
charge or I'm releasing a positron and I
Drive it's here in this equation this is
a positron positron so this type of
decay of seven beryllium to seven
lithium is positron emission fair enough
now let's look at the next one we have
uranium 238 decaying to thorium 234 we
see that the atomic mass
is decreasing by 4-4 and you see that
your atomic number is decrease or your
protons are decreasing by 2 so you must
be releasing essentially something that
has an atomic mass of 4 and an atomic
number of 2 or or a helium so this is
alpha decay so this right here is an
alpha particle alpha particle and this
this is an example of alpha decay now
you're probably saying hey Sal wait
something weird is happening here
because if I just go from 92 protons to
90 protons I still have my 92 electrons
out here so wouldn't I now have a minus
2 charge and even better I
that's this helium I'm releasing this
helium it doesn't have any electrons
with it it's just a helium nucleus so
doesn't that have a plus 2 charge and if
you said that you would be absolutely
correct but the reality is is that right
when this decay happens this thorium it
has no reason to hold on to those two
electrons so those two electrons
disappear and thorium becomes neutral
again and this helium likewise it is
very quick it really wants two electrons
to get stable so it's very quick to grab
two electrons out of the wherever it's
bumping into and so that becomes stable
so you could write it either way now
let's do another one so here I have
iodine release let's see what's
happening my my mass is not changing so
I must have just I must just have
protons turning into neutrons or
neutrons turning into protons and I see
here that I have 53 protons and now I
have 54 protons so I must have a neutron
must have turned into a proton a neutron
must have gone to a proton and the way
that a neutron goes to a proton is by
releasing an electron and we see that in
this reaction right here an electron has
been released and so this is beta decay
this is a beta particle beta this is
beta decay and that same logic holds
like hey wait I just went from 53 to 54
protons don't I have you know what now
that I have this extra proton won't I
have a positive charge here well
would but very quickly this might get
maybe it'll get it's probably won't get
this exact electrons there's so many
electrons running around but it would
grab some electrons some from someplace
to get stable and then it'll be stable
again but you're completely right and
thinking hey wouldn't it be an ion for
some small amount of time now let's do
one more so we have two twenty-two radon
it has an atomic number of eighty six
going to two eighteen polonium with
atomic number of eighty-four and this
actually is an interesting aside
polonium is named after Poland because
Marie Curie she she at the time Poland
this was at the the turn of the last
century around of 1800s Poland didn't
exist as a separate country it was split
between Prussia Russia and Austria and
they really wanted to let people know
that hey you know this we think we're
one people so they they discovered that
when you know radon decayed it formed
the settlement they named it after their
motherland after Poland so just a well
it's the privileges of discovering new
elements but anyway back to the problem
so what happened our atomic mass went
down by four our atomic number went down
by two once again we must have released
a helium particle something a helium
nucleus something that has an atomic
mass of four and a and a atomic number
of two and so that there we are so this
is alpha decay alpha decay and this is
we could write this as a helium nucleus
so it has no electrons and we could even
say immediately that this would have a
negative charge but then it loses